[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
d'association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Chantal Paoli Texier
présidente de l'association AJC bonjour
Alors l'association agissait lutte pour
les droits des victimes de violence
morale intrafamiliale vous existez
depuis 1999 quels sont vos missions et
objectifs au quotidien alors notre
mission principale c'est accompagner les
victimes à la sortie d'emprise à pouvoir
affronter ce qui va se passer quand elle
décide de quitter l'auteur par rapport à
la justice par rapport aux intervenants
etc ça c'est vraiment notre mission
principale après nous avons des missions
annexes qui sont la recherche donc nous
sommes des chercheurs constamment on
essaye d'améliorer les outils de prise
en charge et même la connaissance de la
violence morale et puis nous sommes
aussi nous avons une
mission qui est de sensibiliser
et de aussi enfin deux missions
sensibiliser dénoncer les violences
morales pour essayer de les faire
reconnaître
sont courantes et pourtant la prise de
conscience est parfois difficile donc
quand commence une violence et surtout à
partir de quand on peut la définir comme
une violence alors ça devient une
violence à partir du moment où le mépris
le dénigrement les humiliations sont
véritablement réitérer c'est pas parce
qu'on dit tu es folle dans le feu de
l'action une fois que c'est une violence
c'est plutôt
pas acceptable mais ça constitue pas une
violence morale c'est vraiment la
réitération qui en fait des violences
après c'est vrai que c'est une forme de
violence qui prend
qui est invisible et insidieuse
insidieuse donc c'est cette répétition
qui finit par entrer dans la tête dans
le cerveau dans le corps et c'est une
violence qui est en fait atteint
l'intérieur de soi l'intégrité voilà
c'est ça c'est en fait une violence ça
va pas être spécialement des insultes
pures et dur qu'on peut entendre tous
les jours mais ça peut être tout
simplement tes bonnes à rien ou tu me
sers à rien déjà ça quand c'est répété
ça reste une une violence dénigrement
c'est la violence première ça a été même
considéré en jurisprudence comme une
maltraitance envers les enfants le fait
que leur mère ou leur père soit dénigrés
c'est pas suffisamment appliqué mais
c'est intéressant de voir que quand même
les juristes ont pris ça en
compte c'est vraiment une violence qui
est faite de mots de regard de
comportements mais sans trace alors
justement la justice évolue depuis
plusieurs années sur la thématique des
violences en termes générales pourtant
c'est un terme qui est parfois difficile
à prouver devant un tribunal surtout
quand on parle de violence morale alors
que dit la loi concernant les violences
morales et que risque qu'un auteur de
violence alors la violence morale en
tant que telle c'est un terme générique
nous utilisons qui recouvre la violence
psychologique le harcèlement et la
manipulation donc elle elle n'est pas
prise en considération par la justice
par contre il existe depuis 2010 les
délits de violences psychologiques et
les délits de harcèlement et le délit de
harcèle qui sont un peu trop
malheureusement intriqués là l'un
l'autre ce qui fait que on voit que
manifestement les magistrats trouvent
que le délit de violence psychologique
est trop subjectif donc il est très peu
appliqué et que il se sert finalement du
délit de harcèlement pour pouvoir
rentrer dans aussi dans la violence
psychologique alors entre ce qu'on
risque juridiquement parlant et
l'application de la loi il y a quand
même deux poids de mesure c'est que bien
souvent entre
ce qui est écrit dans le texte et
l'application c'est quand même pas grand
chose et malheureusement nous avons plus
de rappel à la loi que de véritables
condamnations en plus alors justement
face à face à ce constat certaines
personnes n'ose pas en parler préfère
finalement ce terre rester dans le
silence vous au sein de votre
association vous accueillez justement et
accompagner toutes les personnes
victimes de violences morales
intrafamiliales c'est à dire les enfants
les femmes ou encore les âmes alors quel
est le public qui fait le plus souvent
appel à vous alors c'est majoritairement
des femmes nous avons 12% d'hommes moi
je pense que c'est très très en de ça
des chiffres véritables
des violences commises envers les hommes
mais voilà donc majoritairement des
femmes qui ont besoin d'un soutien à
pouvoir affronter ce qui va se passer
après la séparation comme je le disais
précédemment c'est-à-dire à la
séparation c'est quand même le lieu de
tous les dangers donc est-ce qu'il faut
porter plainte est-ce qu'il faut
intenter une action aussi vide
quelles sont les conditions dans
lesquelles nous sommes pour pouvoir
mettre en place quelque chose de
juridique qui va être protecteur
et en règle générale c'est très
compliqué parce que porter plainte en
matière de violence morale c'est
quasiment impossible parfois il y a
aussi l'enfant qui qui est derrière et
qui peut justement empêcher encore un
peu plus de de venir vous voir ou même
de porter plainte alors comment est-ce
que vous véhiculabiliser aussi
les enfants non c'est plutôt un facteur
qui pousse les victimes à venir nous
voir
par contre c'est souvent un facteur qui
empêche de porter plainte effectivement
après tout le travail que nous allons
faire d'accompagnement c'est une mise en
verbalisation de ce qui est vécu une
mise en compréhension de ce qui est vécu
et donc effectivement de
déculpabilisation donc on va bien
expliquer ce que ça veut dire la
violence parce que on a affaire à des
femmes et des hommes qui ont perdu tous
leurs repères qui n'ont plus de normes
qui ne savent même plus ce qui est bien
ce qui n'est pas bien ce qui est normal
ce qui pas normal et donc on va devoir
nommer nommer la violence
nommer ce qu'ils ont vécu très
spécifiquement et un exemple frappant
que nous avons c'est que bien souvent
les victimes quand elles commencent à
raconter leur histoire là d'abord elle
minimise énormément mais par exemple
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est très à
la violence sexuelle et au viol n'est
jamais mentionné dans un premier temps
en entretien ça vient toujours après ça
vient toujours alors souvent en groupe
de parole d'ailleurs parce que c'est là
que la parole se libère le plus mais ça
vient toujours après et là on découvre
que effectivement
la violence
conjugale intrafamiliale s'accompagne
effectivement de violences sexuelles
alors la sensibilisation est aujourd'hui
importante que mettez-vous en place pour
sensibiliser justement les différents
publics à la violence morale
intrafamiliale alors nous avons un axe
depuis
le confinement en fait depuis 2020
de sensibilisation qui m'intéresse
vraiment beaucoup par les raisons on
utilise énormément les réseaux avec même
des on a fait un effort de d'être dans
quelque chose de pratique au pratique
avec des petites fiches techniques etc
bon on a nos deux ouvrages aussi qui
sont censés sensibiliser mais il y en a
un qui est en fin de finition mais qui
se trouve encore en format Kindle
et puis on a des des petites actions de
sensibilisation sur des conférences soit
avec des partenaires et surtout surtout
avec des formations pour les
pour tout intervenant qui est en lien
avec cette forme de violence alors vous
agissez autour de quatre axes pour pour
les rappeler défendre accompagner
sensibiliser et dénoncer on a parlé donc
de la sensibilisation et de
l'accompagnement on va parler de la
défense et du de la dénonciation
finalement vous avez notamment fait
plusieurs plaidoyer pour faire évoluer
la justice et la reconnaissance des
victimes de violences morales
psychologique sur le plan juridique
quels sont vos ambitions justement sur
sur ces thématiques alors nos ambitions
c'est essayer effectivement de de
pouvoir être reçu déjà par le ministère
de la justice parce que nous avons été
reçus par le ministère du droit des
femmes et auxquelles auprès duquel nous
avons pu vraiment confier certaines
choses et nous nous espoirs en matière
d'avancée mais notre interlocuteur
principal ça devrait être le ministère
de la Justice bon c'est un peu compliqué
mais on
persiste et on espère bien y arriver
parce que ce que nous a renvoyé un peu
le ministère du droit des femmes avec
raison c'est que on a quand même besoin
d'un agrément pour pouvoir véritablement
dans nos axes sensibilisés et
accompagnés être reconnu être soutenu
être
alors c'est pas visible mais
légitime il faut finalement rendre
visible l'invisible briser ses tabous et
ce silence pour faire évoluer la justice
et faire prendre conscience aux victimes
qu'elles ne sont pas fautives encore une
fois les déculpabiliser c'est un travail
qui est constant de déculpabiliser les
victimes surtout quand la justice ne
nous accompagne pas quand les jugements
vont à l'encontre de leur intérêt de
leur protection c'est on se retrouve
avec des mères qu'on dit des enfantés
c'est-à-dire que les enfants sont sous
emprises et qu'elles n'ont plus de lien
avec eux on se retrouve avec des mers
qui n'ont plus leur enfant en garde
parce que c'est l'auteur qui les a des
enfants qui sont très très abîmés ce
fameux stress post traumatique dont
parle le livre blanc sur les enfants
exposés aux violences conjugales nous on
constate tous les jours c'est un
accompagnement constant mais on peut de
toute façon retrouver plus
d'informations sur votre site AJC
violence point org merci beaucoup
Chantal paolith excédé avoir été avec
nous sur sensation donc je rappelle que
vous êtes la présidente de l'association
agissez si vous êtes victime de violence
physique sexuelle ou morale de numéro
existe le 119 pour les enfants le 39-19
pour les femmes et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]